we have this lamb this lamp will keep us
warm through tonight through the winters
is there any way we are gonna see what's
going on you're just telling us it's a
game of telephone Ron the stream the
stream is we're in the stream it's
hitting us we're into data streams
you're loving him in the stream okay
well we are streams hit me with the
goods
oh hi Internet hey I'm coding
he's Cody I'm Paige ooh this is our land
no they cannot sue it okay Wow well then
they can't see what shape it is cuz it's
really inappropriate oh yeah not safe
for street oh okay so hi everybody
hey jr. Cody and we're gonna be drawing
yeah whatever you tell us just so start
giving us stuff hit us with the stuff
give us great juicy suggestions good and
we will draw them for your viewing
pleasure there they're flying it oh my
god
oh my god oh and then this is Matt
you're not gonna see me I'm behind the
camera
Matt is our ghost moderator too bad you
can't see Matt because he floats and
it's very impressive it's very
impressive very impressive exactly seven
inches off the ground
ooh I guess I have a lot of power here I
see a lot of good suggestions oh boy our
fate is in your ghostly hands man like
that yep let's do let's start with this
would be hey Jones
you both same one UFO piloted by a cow
UFO piloted by a cow okay
[Music]
I'm guessing people are still feeling
the storming area 51 means pretty
can you I'm out of the loop a June tell
me about storming area 51
actually I don't know the context I just
went on Twitter and all of a sudden
everybody was the thing hey let's storm
every 51 I was like okay I guess this is
a meme and I shrugged it off and did you
storm area 51 I don't think the storming
has happened yet okay it is to be
determined hey you know okay where's
that thing in Photoshop I wear I can
like roll my hand up and down with the
zoom button and make it zoom in and out
it's like kind of more fluid I don't
have to tap you know I'm talking about I
dunno I I am NOT a Photoshop master I do
not know the hotkeys I give up it's okay
so they can influence these drawings as
well so it's a cow being piloted by a
UFO yeah we already have our first
edition okay it count that ate a UFO and
is floating in the air
wouldn't it be funny if it was a cow
being piloted by a UFO I think this is
up to your discretion technically I
can't stop you Wow the cow is joined by
Peppa Pig no boy what's that
it's is that a specific pig it's a very
specific Pig it's a beloved children's
Pig very very specific shapes how do I
spell it
PEP pa pig eye all again PEP pa like
like pet pepper but oh okay look but an
a not an ER all right well let me let me
look into that voice presumably spicy
pigs you imagine of imagine a pig that
smells like pepper that's Peppa Pig
right I forgot what counsel like so I'm
going to draw a farsighted cow
if anybody knows that comic reference
kudos to you I've had a book of farside
comics on my shelf that somebody gave me
and I've been meaning to read it for
years it's it's really a niche I like it
it's very charming the Gary Larson was a
marine biologist so that's how he got
his start he was like kind of like
Stephen Hillenburg that's crazy yeah I
was just gonna say why is this a thing
why does that translate so well in the
cartoonists I guess it's kind of a
cartoony profession like studying fish I
think so just like trying trying to make
deep like scientific research with like
if creators started just floating in the
water I'm gonna remind myself of what
Peppa Pig looks like as well because I
think we can do it okay so generic Pig
okay I'll just draw a slop peg should we
do salt pig uh mustard pig oh yeah okay
we're doing mustard Pig Peppa Pig is
such good memes
what does a hogshead look let's go trust
now and Iran thing it's a pic now hey
Jun did you grow up wanting to be an
animator I did actually
never ever since yeah I like like I I
was the kid that was like making flip
books on like post-it notes so there's
somewhere in my parent Department in
Korea are the dusty old post-it notes
full of full animated stick figures
doing violent things because this that's
apparently what your enemy when you
first animate things you just draw like
violent stick figure animations because
do you think that's cool
I think I did something similar like did
you always want to do animation work I
didn't know that was a job and in fact
when I would see it in movies where he'd
be like this guy's job is like you know
cartoonists I'd be like yeah okay that's
just a thing for like a kids movie I
didn't really understand how they were
made
and I didn't even heard of certain art
jobs and I went to like a portfolio
review for like the one job I knew was
like an art job maybe I would go to
college for and it was a like graphic
design and so I was like everyone knew
of graphic design and architect but it
was like everybody in my class it's like
if like everyone would be an architect I
was like I don't know maybe I'll look at
the graphic design and then except
really want to make buildings either and
then when I looked I looked at my
portfolio all the ladies at the
portfolio review thing like hey this is
a more like an illustration portfolio
and I'd never heard of that job well but
I was like cool that's like I guess I'd
seen that on books but I didn't really
think that was like a real career option
so I went to like school went to Pratt
for that and then like first semester
there I heard something about the
animation department and then I was like
oh
obviously like somebody must make those
I just never thought about it in that
way
nobody and you did that so I I knew
people would made like new ground stuff
but I thought like people who worked at
Disney or somewhere like that they just
like and I guess I thought maybe like
their parents got them jobs or something
I didn't really process because I was
just from Texas and like nobody I knew
did that really are you from Texas
did I tell you that I was born in Texas
now I was I was born in Texas and I was
a four pound premature baby and my
parents so we back to Korea they're
probably oh yeah
how are you stay in Korea nine years I
really early childhood okay let's see I
think wait so can people can see our
screens oh yeah they can oh boy
[Music]
so it's a mustard pig and a cow I think
I think so mustard do we have anything
else on the cow like I need to know more
about this cow what's going on with this
cow is he is he happy driving it is he
being held hostage by the pig is the cow
taking the pig to the hospital and the
pigs like bleeding out from a laser
wound I need more information we want to
know we want to know your headcanon
about mustard Pig what is your pain
tonight what's your headcanon about this
pig in town by the way pig has you know
a description now he's at least mustard
pig I can do something with that I don't
know what about this cow I'm my pig is
very bored in destroying while the cows
screaming I got it I got a good
suggestion from Jason Brown the cow has
graduated top of his class at MIT so
this is the cows thesis that's funny
very specific very specific know what to
do with that thank you is that Jason
Brown thanks Jason Brown thank you Jason
Brown I hope you had a good time at the
graduation
if that is where you graduated from I
think that was just the cow no she says
it's a cow Jason Brown is if a cow can
do it you can do it to use the oldest
fan
right okay wait the count just graduated
so I have to put it in a ceremonial gown
I think this is probably a post
graduation celebration they are going to
party and probably do some some underage
drinking and I hope they drive that UFO
responsibly clearly they're not they're
drunk they're drunk farm animals I like
to think that maybe this cow is the
designated driver and the pig is drunk
on mustard
yeah mustard pig that is and you know
that future alcoholic right there folks
if you find yourself chugging mustard by
the bottle seek help yeah it's not a
good place it's not a good place to be
take it from mustard Pig hey else must
have Pig right there I have a good
suggestion you can you don't the draw it
immediately think about it mac aid
suggests that the pig is the significant
other hmm okay so think on that I'm
ruminating on this new relationship okay
so they're going to like party after you
know you finally graduate and got into
the good school so there's probably like
some party down by the interstellar
Creek or something in a southern creek
space spin-off of Dawson's Creek I can I
can just hear the soft guitar intro in
my head all the original cast make
cameos and like weird alien costumes as
farm animals yeah
while you guys are drawing I have a
question do you guys each have your own
specific set of Photoshop brushes I do
not I wish I was more Pro enough to have
that but I don't use Photoshop enough to
have those brushes sets yeah I feel like
oh my drawing at this point is really
utilitarian it because it's just like
move this here and then somebody else
actually does a good version of that
drawing so it's just about like
expressing that idea really quickly so I
don't have any like beautiful Photoshop
brushes I just need to show them with
the draw no boy I gotta get this pig in
here what are colors anybody have any
thoughts on color theory all right I
don't know what colors what what's
what's the what I am MIT colors it's
kind of color do your throat first take
forever
[Music]
oh it's coming out like Miss Piggy okay
yes yes I'm all here for this mustard
Pig mustard M pig well she's obviously
gotta be yellow something yellow going
on a little mustard stain on her Miss
Piggy's actual for native mustard piggie
Mr piggy yes that did not work I tried
it and I will jump into the hole that I
made so uh Langlois up I'm pronouncing
that right is very insistent on a pink
Oh a pink cow I can make that happen
I can I can also make this happen this
we can make those dreams come true we
will genetically modify cows to be pink
only
oh man I spent too much time worrying
about the language
okay
mmm all right pink pink cap pink cow
let's do this a little rushed yeah we'll
see
[Music]
oh boy okay no don't make everything
pink that's that's not how that's not
how this works
who works for me oh boy okay that's
that'll do think count pink ow
now I have just the music that please
from Dumbo playing my head can you hum
it for me well it's a mr. pink elephant
song and I don't know if I can do that
I'll copyright yeah and yeah boyee
copyright our best friend can you hum it
backwards
Cody Mack aid says Cody's adorable oh oh
so working out then thank you
thank you also where was the can't
remember I lost it
it was dragon art I think silver dragon
art suggest that if the cow is pink the
pig has to be green
oh no if it's a theory or what what does
a gold dragon art think we're waiting
for the response I want to you know run
that through and make sure all the
dragons approve so we don't have any
like inner dragon area arguments but
I'll make it green for now oh I'm coming
to pick mustard well mustard pig for me
has got mustard clothing but mustard
clothing I mean she's a green
I'm going time running low on time oh
boy
to protect others
OOP
what happened
I accidentally cropped everything
nothing almost oh I didn't mean to
specify he's much bigger so that I can
actually color it any faster
there we go that's better no there's
nothing wrong I don't know I don't know
MIT colors also gonna use this dark teal
oh those are boring Cairo no actually
well the cow itself is pink meaning it's
a fusion of two of those colors the
genus is done we gotta rip her glasses
off dramatically we do okay
okay I feel like it's been time yeah
he's gonna start wrapping it up oh boy
Cody what's the number on the oh I'm
just kind of always ripping off Toriyama
a little bit so he always just throws
random numbers and stuff onto some
things I can resign element I get
verified that is true Tommy Adrian also
put a number on nice well then there you
go it's a tradition here at buzz of uses
you're gonna make it cool slap a number
on it if anybody asked what it's about
you just laugh and walk away you laugh
you shrug you walk away quietly do you
guys have a favorite number that you put
on things not for 20 not on okay you
know actually I do this all the time and
I don't think I don't consciously have a
go-to but it would be interesting to
reexamine if I did the same number every
time and didn't know it or something
like I feel like you do that and the
x-files theme is gonna if you followed
like one of your friends around and just
waited for like funny opportunities you
just blast the x-files theme you get a
laugh like 80% of the time that's just a
solid guy it's such a funny and like
dramatic just boom tintin tintin tintin
you know I'm I'm pretty much there I
just wanna know
you see we're gonna have a good time
partying but mustard pig is probably
gonna throw up mustard pig oh you party
too hard
okay hey Jun how you feeling about your
your party animals chaotic I don't I
feel like I'm looking at the colors
right now I feel if it feels like it
belongs into Rugrats the colors fun this
is just bizarre Eastern European colors
yes yes I would I would assess as such
okay that's cool that's as much as I
doesn't wasn't gonna do
okay call this done
so how do you think you did Cody it's
weird if I saw this out of context like
on my Instagram feed I wouldn't know
what to make of it and I would just like
keep scrolling I think I also might stop
and go I have a lot of questions here
and that's an interesting thing i think
i i i also feel those sentiments if I
saw this out of context there'll be
questions but it'll be up to my brain to
decide should I ask him or move on but I
I'm happy with the screaming cow let me
ask you is your mustard Pig going to
probably throw up after the party
tonight or is it a different situation
with yours I think mustard Pig is just
over it okay can't wait to see her yeah
I can't wait to see I can't wait to see
your interpretation
- yes that is very Toriyama yeah oh man
I like the storytelling involved with
this like graduated married thing like
it was perhaps hijacked the way is the
story of this that this sort of over at
mustard pig is forcing the graduation
cow to get married like a shotgun
wedding yes they're going to flank Las
Vegas so funny
why does mustard peak look so calm and
graduation cows so scared I may be
mustard pig is just stoned and is very
calm about all this chaos very
tumultuous I really love that mustard
pig is just a regular pig I'm one of the
very literal interpretation of the Proms
that's a way fun of your character like
if they were in the show mustard Pig
just never said anything it was just
like he's made pig noises IIIi love I
love this this embrace that your
characters are in it's it's it's it's
like you you did there's palpable
tension and in you you hope that the cow
will land a UFO safely mm-hmm III like
to start telling in this and also I love
that you gave the account of big glasses
because the cow is very smart that's how
you know that's how you know where's
where are they
that's how you know you know
that's how you know that's how you know
Mike how I think I think they'll make it
through the night you know he's not
gonna crash the UFO but they're gonna
have to have a serious talk before he
goes off to MIT and my story mm-hmm
also I want to point out I love the
doughnut shape of a UFO it's it's very
dimensional love the dome I forget the
dome but my effort does not have it
don't
oh yeah the bubble dome I don't have it
I never miss the opportunity for a
bubble dome I love a good dome but I
don't know if my characters will make it
through tonight it seems that there
there's smoke coming out of the UFO we
don't know if they're gonna crash crash
land into a Las Vegas Taco Bell where
they can get married but stay tuned for
their wedding hopefully hopefully
thanks please Assiut farm animals yes
thank you very much I um I I'm glad to
be able to get so much attitude in such
a short amount of time a lot of a lot of
great creation collaborative stories
forming look look out for mustard Pig
and pink cow coming to vh1 and VHS VHS
and and 8-millimeter we're gonna make it
that's we're gonna be handing them out
on Hollywood and Vineland so catches
they're handing out the adjusted our
cartoon we're alive
can I see my ship oh whoa you saw over
there how do you watch it oh okay
give me some of the Mia link it's it's
in the it's in this slack it's on your
slacks this is Matt again
disembodied voice while everyone learns
how livestreams work let's start getting
suggestions for what Nick and Kyra will
draw flowing in that chat boy happy to
stop you need to stop stop recording
okay cool cool all right all set here
come on IP the excitement applied film
oh my god we're here to drop for you hi
Internet hi thank you for coming yes hi
I'll see you tonight I shout out my
family probably not watching but if I
love you I don't I know frog faces
though right frog face yeah I have weird
friends all right and while they're
getting their drawings ready well let's
let's shout out some people Lang more
thank you for your suggestions you've
been great so far
Natalie Estrada thanks for joining us
The Adventures of ghost Godzilla one two
three four welcome shadow Slayer Sara
Lima lol Kate I just said cakes lol cake
what up yo what up girl we don't know
that's cross Kim lip Dave Miller
Christian Sanchez
I'm just like doodling right now Multi
worm
yeah I think so
David OBS Leo Wang yeah start streamer
start recording yep Marian Garcia has to
be quiet now because they're gonna
record something we're ready I start hey
I'm Kiera hey I'm Nick today we're gonna
be drawing whatever the internet wants
us to hmm make it something fun got a
lot of good suggestions I bet there's a
lot of good suggestions oh man oh this
is an interesting one I just wanna shout
it out I don't think we should do it
this is Cassidy Frederick says please do
the jetsons or a dachshund which is I
like those the spectrum there it's a
good Spectre wait the Jetsons it's like
the cartoon and then a dachshund like
the dub as in a dachshund or the Jetsons
as it wait was it those dog wasn't the
dog like a dark Cinco no God was nice Oh
like a great day
hi ooh I like this one where were you at
here here here hold wrote I lost it's
and real quick shoes do that's scary
let's see I'm gonna find it I'm gonna
find it and I start mixing up some of
these suggestions oh I like this one
here this is a mixture of Sophie kids
and then one I can't find anymore let's
do a French giraffe lifting weights a
French draught lifting weights okay you
can veto it
I'll tell them okay no if you want to do
something different than C's hey well I
mean I don't want to crush their dream
that was it that was a mixture of a
couple that I was trying to please
everyone
let's do differently it's just gonna
make me think of exercise and then
remind me that I haven't exercised and
and that we should all exercise folks
cuz you know it's important to stay
healthy
especially when you sit on your button
draw all day I'm gonna okay I'm gonna
start shouting him out and then if you
one grabs you guys it was the animated
gut yeah dinosaur playing basketball
against a ghost on the moon while
juggling on a unicycle I got well can't
do that sorry I won't say it out loud
a lion playing ping-pong with a leopard
what an animal stuff what a lot of
animals do
[Music]
let's see let's see a lot of copy
written stuff guys
what would you drop in stuff oh ooh
I'll I would personally like to see a
cat doing pottery okay and the silence
in the room suggests why not I'd like to
as well or a unicorn playing the piano
unicorn I want to draw a unicorn what's
your name Nick you're on a unicorn
pottery with a unicorn like in that
seems like you know and we'll just sing
we'll just sing Unchained Melody the
whole time
a unicorn playing piano yeah oh all
right I'm gonna do a cat in a unicorn
doing pottery together we love we would
all love to see that that's you know so
I'm gonna be drawing a unicorn playing
the piano and Nick I'm gonna be drawing
a cat kitty cat in a majestic unicorn
doing pottery together probably go style
for all you who don't know what ghost is
it's a movie from the 90s you should
watch it it's an appropriate
it's got flippy Goldberg in it and it's
great it's been a while since you've
been under off Nick it has been a while
does it feel uh it feels like I never
left
that's good feels like I'm just always
here drawing even when you're at your
desk wouldn't watch always here
I don't know how to draw a piano that's
me four everywhere just like I want to
draw this thing I don't know how to do
it okay okay so right now I'm just kind
of blocking in I'm just speeding into
this mm-hmm
Kitty's gonna be small so it's like
looking to the side like wow we're due
to lot some Yowie so I apologize
I had to meow in the vo booth today you
did yeah if my voice sounds Scratchy
it's because we were recording and what
were you recording the good advice
that's right what were you recording I
was recording the good advice cupcake
too but I I'm just playing the part of
the neighbor howdy
in an upcoming episode that you'll all
love just want to give a quick shout out
to crazy doc thank you for the
suggestion of the cat doing pottery I'm
so sorry guys
I had no idea that we couldn't do
copyrighted character was telling people
on Twitter to send me copyright oh I'm
sorry
well I drew him a little bit before we
started
horn Tooting unicorns and cats are very
popular I mean why not you know they're
so cute
it's killing like a Cheshire grin mmm
I'm a big fan of unicorn cat hybrids
here this is something to think about
Aiden Glore just said there should be a
cat on the piano singing you think about
it whether you want to do that or not
oh that's so cute I could do that she
should play one of those like cat pianos
that you get at Target that's also
copier that's all I can think about I'm
drawing a non known kitty cat with a
unicorn that nobody knows ever existed
this is a Knick original likes collodion
I haven't heard that before
I'm only gonna speak in things that are
covered let's get us D monitors
so we see okay so unicorns gotta be
majestic by majestic I mean I don't know
how to draw horse we both took options
that were like yeah unicorn let's try
this again
you guys can definitely use reference if
you need yeah you guys are wondering
what I'm doing right now I'm just kind
of roughing out like rough placement
helps me to kind of see what's sort of
in cuz in my head right now it's like I
sort of have like a fuzzy idea of what I
want to draw it's not really clear
enough some people they're just like
boom they know exactly what they want to
draw on they're just like but for me
it's sort of like a like a like an
exploration like I'm trying to explore
and figure out what I'm trying to you
know draw and it's just like if it looks
right and then I start going like okay
you're trying to find yourself yeah
honestly that's it forever like even
when you become a professional artist
you're always just gonna be like I have
no idea what I'm doing yeah very much
you never will
impostor syndrome will rule your life do
you ever get that imposter syndrome yeah
yeah um happens all the time that
happens anytime somebody complements me
I'm like Sarah I bet you're just awesome
I don't deserve that compliment and bad
this is like a children's piano I just
realized I made this unicorn way too big
that I won't be able to fit the horn
let's shrink them down everything is
held together by tripods this is a fun
note at this point Micah Pittman thinks
that Kyra's unicorn looks like it's
getting her nails done oh that's so
cheap get your nails did well it's more
copyrighted content that's speaking pink
so weird
I love it though I'm excited to see it
you're doing the ghost thing yeah I have
a copyrighted song stuck on my head
I won't sing again so everyone ghost is
a story about a man who is in love with
a woman played by Demi Moore and Patrick
Swayze
I'm already four and Patrick Swayze dies
and he has to like go and talk to his
lover because she's in trouble
so Whoopi Goldberg a psychic and he's
all like yo Whoopi you got to help me
and she's like oh this is so weird and
he's like no please you got a and so he
starts seeing Henry the Eighth I am I am
over and over again until she would and
she's like okay and lead her and it
basically ends with Whoopi Goldberg and
Demi Moore on a pottery wheel it because
she possesses he possesses Whoopi
Goldberg
it's a weird movie I don't know man
there's like demons in it at the end
it's it's some crazy out of the 90s were
crazy there's demons and that's a movie
review by Nick V Terra yay and that's a
movie review I Nick be Tara
I've never seen it but I've seen that
scene I've only seen it like once that's
why you barely remember because you hate
Oh Mike I just made this late bloomer
corn we haven't drawn in a while
oh my god I gotta give this like a
beautiful just mane of hair yeah Sparkle
magic just flowing everywhere
I love it my unicorn looks more like a
cow
Kirra if you have time yes Leo Wang
suggested the unicorn can be playing the
piano for a crowd of cats oh my gosh
just have to be like a big blob of cats
this is mostly draw off just us sitting
in silence I I just I have the main song
from ghost just stuck at the hold it
like sitting here I wish there's a song
called ghost
I can't think Kevin is telling me that
you guys could you come up with a back
story for my little unicorn I'm drawing
if that's okay
how are you feeling about your driving
um it's something Oh
Oh No um can I say this it's trying to
capture the love that is happening
majestic love between the unicorn and a
kitty and I don't know if I'm gonna get
the color bebe gr suggests that she just
broke up with her boyfriend and is
writing a song about it obviously she's
pretty happy about it
Maria de suggests that the unicorn moved
from Idaho to Hollywood to pursue her
musical career wholesome and cute
when you're laughing at your own drawing
that's usually good I think it's just so
ridiculous oh my god I gotta get to
color though I want to put so much pink
on this
I'm just going going at it raw no sketch
cat is going to be blue
I hope y'all enjoying us watching us
draw love to watch some you all draw
sometime man draw versus ya draw off
versus the Internet
there's a website that's coming back
where you can draw with other people we
should do it oh that's really cool or do
a that program that where you could draw
people it'll be us fighting the audience
who's trying to erase Archer
that sounds awesome
I just want to shout out a lot of these
back stories for the unicorns are so
well thought out and touching if I read
them I might cry oh my god wait I need
to have the cat not looking you can't
needs to hop you just looking at the
cats looking lovingly at the unicorn
horse
I'm having fun man this drawing is crazy
and fun and weird I don't think I'm
gonna get the color but I'm gonna try
you can do it boys color palette um I do
not wake up this morning and think I'm
gonna draw a cat and a unicorn making a
pot neckline Internet I want to thank
all I want to thank you Internet for
continuing to inspire me with weird
ideas because that's what the Internet's
all about I mean you've heard the
wholesomeness bringing the world
together and weirdness it could have
been weirder that's true this is very
wholesome that's all I wanted wha
wholesome
there are certainly weird of suggestions
I mean saving them for Jason and Brent
yeah oh my gosh yeah those guys they are
the perfect ones this oh this
perspective is wrong
I don't even have to animate today yeah
just get to draw music notes go oh my
god I'm Scioscia myself I drew a drawing
recently and I drew a character's hand
backwards that's that's like I'm so dumb
people do that all the time it's okay a
failure is an animator they're gonna
blacklist we all have our moments cuz
you get you're getting a drawing and you
forget you're just like oh go on and
then you're like oh everything about
this is wrong like if I took this
drawing and flipped it which is by the
way a great thing you can do when your
drawing is draw and then flip the
drawing like if I took this and reversed
it I probably would just be like I see
all sorts of problem you like to cry um
yeah I was like half asleep when I drew
it which is a lot of my drawings
nowadays because I'll come from come
home from work be super tired but I'm
like really put a draw and then I'll
draw something weird yeah it's it's it's
a challenge when you draw all day and
then you come home but the thing is it's
like you just love it you just draw I
can't stop I know people are like oh
it's really cool that you really can
remember these characters I mean it's
not it's really sad that's all I do I
just draw cartoons all the time having
your Instagram awesome boring person and
no you're not boring y'all haven't you
gotta check out her Instagram it's
freaking awesome
so barren yours is beautiful I'm glad
that you're on it more I'm trying I need
a new art website we all do okay I'm
getting there I'm gonna leave it
we might have to just say no color
usually folks I usually stay within the
lines but I'm on a time limit here so
yes all are gonna be a little sloppy all
our drafts are on a time limit so hence
the quick sketches maybe one time we'll
do a long okay let's get something on
[Music]
brington Jason are here
hmm going for some weird colors now I
heard to see yours see the pot it's just
gonna I was gonna shade the pot but you
know I don't have time I just totally
went into that hand okay
and hoofs I don't know what color hoofs
are so they're gonna be gray blue pink
and a nice I don't know
oh the horn
the most important part oh my god we got
to make the horn pop we'll just make the
corn like a bunch of rainbow colors
wasn't I'm on wrong layer
sorry Internet I'm trying to make it
awesome for you there we go I hope you
enjoy this unicorns sitting in kind of
an uncomfortable position I got to do a
otherworldly unicorn glow cuz the
Unicorn is sort of you know it goes oh
well it's already 400 it's unicorn go
say they're magical it's a magic kinda
like it's a magical creature but she's
also kind of a ghost
I mean unicorns die right
no they're no they're immortal yeah oh
well not this unicorn listen this
unicorn got the short end of the stick
okay done out tap whoo done
how do you think you dig here as I
continue finishing up it's over
put your pocket I think I did ok uh I
definitely trolled around with it but
it's a horse how about you
I drew now looking at it what looks like
a cow horse unicorn holding a pot with
the cat but they're making pottery I
like it
it's weird I like it I'm glad I'm glad
you like I actually like something I did
that's amazing
good you need to like all the things
Thank You internet Thank You internet it
was really fun I'm gonna get emotional
very cool oh my God look just gonna
stare at you Internet until I can look
what's up Internet
oh my god
yours is amazing oh em gee you're
adorable PG here is so good at drawing
cute stuff so good yours this Oh No
yours is good
no no background you're all like I don't
know I do a background I just went fill
yellow okay quick background fill yellow
opacity down to 30% use the soft brush
it go it looks like a background oh I
love this I love
oh it's beautiful see you got the
majestic pink healing of a unit you need
to know me this unicorn is like she's
like oh yours is so good like it's
hilarious I love the character face it's
so good Nick see everyone drawings
awesome just don't stop drawing okay
it's so much fun I want to do it more
often drop drawing with the internet
suggests is really fun and I want to do
it more internet I love drawing for you
like you give us ideas that are amazing
so you can always send me ideas and
maybe I'll draw them on my Instagram I
don't know what yeah take requests you
work with it was fun this was fun it was
so much we're gonna trade off we're done
we're gonna trade up y'all think these
drawings are great and wait till you see
what's coming up ready let's see
Nick while Nick and Kyra swap out for
Jason and Brent let's start just ideas
in the chat for what Jason and grant
might draw Nick crazy doc says thank you
for drawing their suggestion hey any
time thank you
hit me up on instagram animator Nick B
that's what Instagram yeah cuz now
there's stuff on it I'm really I'm
really glad the suggestions for Jason
and Brent are pouring darker okay what
messed up Jason thing do we have to draw
oh man here is so good yeah go ahead and
tell them the things you like to draw
like kind of moods and things moods I
guess I like happy things I like
throwing people I like I don't know
I draw things from life a lot
exaggerated caricatures kind of my jam
not big on animals
what about you Jason what about you
Jason you know I'm more into things that
are animal anima topically correct or
anatomically correct but you know you go
you do whatever you want and I'll like
try to keep up Internet
yeah yeah we are down for whatever
just bring it on we've drawn a lot of
animals so let's start getting some
human type characters yeah let's get
some people up and some people up in
here
yeah and remember we will probably not
draw a copy written material all right
so those keep those suggestions
no copyright fresh I'm good I think I'm
okay all right later
I love these suggestions keep them
rolling in all right what do we got
keep those additions rolling in will we
record an intro
this is BFV 59 75 to Jason and Brent
draw the internet suggestions take one
Parker Jason hi I'm Brent and today
we're drawing hey I'm Jason
hey I'm Brent and today we're drawing
whatever the internet wants yeah
just whatever thought comes to their
mind yeah and I'll add horns and
appendages all of it I trust that the
internet will come up with some
wholesome family-friendly content for us
to enjoy I know this is a replay wait
this is a replay okay this is a replay
of a live stream so if you hear a
disembodied phantom voice coming from
the ether it's the it's our moderator
giving us some suggestions his name is
Big Daddy Matt yeah daddy Matt that's
his name from off screen all right Big
Daddy let's hear it I'm gonna throw some
things at you well shout out some great
suggestions if something grabs you guys
will go over all right let me find some
good ones okay oh I like Bella Jane
suggests a young child who is rocking a
dragon costume I'll keep going if you'd
like one grab oh that's nice young child
rocking a dragon costume yeah okay a
young child we got I like one suggestion
that was just pizza man pizza man I
don't know anything about what that
means okay okay
I think we're gonna do I'm feeling the
dragon kid though do we have to draw the
same thing okay dragon kid all the pizza
man yeah yeah let's switch it up
all right 20 minutes so young child okay
I have got a 19 month old little child
and he is awesome maybe I'll buy him a
dragon costume we're gonna make him a
dragon costume you know what I'm gonna
flip the script on this pizza man drying
y'all thought I was drawing a guy
delivering you pizza mm-hm
think again as you see I erase a lot
Internet the internet will forgive you
okay the Internet's a very forgiving
place Jason oh really
yeah my experience shout-out to Louise
Kiwi for the pizza man suggestion
shout-out to Louise Louise for the pizza
man's suggestion
is a good suggestion here's an honorable
mention from buckle up buckaroo the 24/7
hours our arm scene 127 hours our emcee
Oh Jason Oh God yeah I've suppressed it
for so long and now it's on earth I like
that Jesus I really like I like that
movie a lot that is it it is a great
movie I will see ya wave he cut himself
with two it was it like a rusty knife
rusty knife like it was not not a
pleasant looking knife what is your plan
for pizza man Brant Jason all will be
revealed
yeah you'll find out for yourself it's
already really promising yeah okay so
you're already like deep in there yes I
like really like the 127 our idea I'm
growing up I think I'm gonna try to
combine dragon boy in the hundred and
twenty seven hours yeah I think I think
I got that that's oh my god but I just
need to like like sell it I don't know
how rusty I can get this knife
no no he looks like he's cutting his
wrists nevermind I'm not doing that like
starting OH
veto the hundred and twenty hours
yeah I was oh man but whoever who said
that one great idea I don't know great
idea though let me change this point let
me change this pose then there's an
honorable mention I believe their name
was Brandon from earlier before you were
here Jason but it was cannibal gummy
bears who instantly thought of hannibal
gummy bear wolf call me dog killing it
with these that's good right up your
wheelhouse Jason ok ok ok
y'all are killing me with these
was crazy as I'm just used to drawing
people with with muscles so I'm like
drawing this kid and he's got like great
arms you know yeah okay Peter Parker's a
kid with great arms Peter Parker yeah
kids ripped
all right
I think you'll like my pizza man Jason
I'm sort of channeling a little bit of
you into this oh thank you yeah
yeah any if we have any questions for
these silent drawers okay
hey we're fun I the overall consensus in
the chat not to give anything away for a
Jason is that the pizza man legs are
making them feel some type of way
[Laughter]
um Pizza Man is available for
bachelorette parties I can book now at 1
800
delivery man oh god no I'm making this
oh no I'm going too far I gotta stop
myself I'm so sorry
ok
okay
Jason best pizza that's Pete best pizzas
pizza pepperoni sausage Sanada is not a
weird choice as people would expect but
it's my favorite
what about like pizza chain ooh I don't
have one don't have one I used to work
at Chuck E Cheese oh okay it's like the
bane of my existence I was like oh my
god I hate myself okay but I fell out of
love with like chain pizza after that
mmm have you revisited Little Caesars
recently no I haven't I
I have is one next to my apartment and I
gotta say it surprised me I don't have
the best you know the best brand idea
but it is it was pretty good I'm finally
getting to the point where I'm happy
with the pencils in this in Photoshop no
with the pencils of the drawing that I'm
making right now okay a quick suggestion
take it or leave it
okay Maria D Maria B has been trying to
get a mullet on everything today thinks
that pizza man hates a man's gonna have
a mullet okay you've got your mullet
here we go
Pizza Man mullet that's what we do here
at draw-off live we make dreams come
true
okay you know I gotta say I don't think
I've drawn a mullet just about and ever
but we're gonna make this happen
it's gonna be a cheesy cheese mullet
[Music]
all right guys keep those questions
coming and while you're at it let's
think of the backstory for the pizza man
or this is origin young dragon boy yeah
who does he deliver for who's he working
for I have a question from Marcia Marcia
what's your question
Brent and they'll so this adjacent as
well cuz he's also very good at this how
do you draw human body parts oh well oh
well thanks uh
just hitting your head against the wall
for like a decade I'd say just trying
every freaking day to draw feet and
being really bad at it for most of the
time and then you know one day you'll
wake up and you'll be like oh I get it
I get how I work I my wave is I grew up
drawing superheroes superhero comics and
stuff like that and they're all like
basically like naked bodies with designs
over them and you kind of get a sense
for what the human body looks like even
if it's like completely wrong because
they they're so exaggerated yeah it's
still like pretty a pretty cool cool
like practice yeah and also like just
drawing drawing things really fast I
I've realized helps because it you you
learn to get like the way things flow
yeah if that makes sense
yeah weirdly enough you know in school
they tell you not to I think drawing
comics and stuff even if some anime does
help like if it's something fun that you
want to draw like it helps you learn
about Anatomy while you're doing it
mm-hmm alright I think that's a mullet
I'm trying make like a cheese mullet
it's not it's hard I'm going a little
bit more cartoony for this kid I like
the way it's going so far
I want more so worrisome in my back
sorry though
you guys you've birthed this creature I
need to know where he comes from
where does Pizza Man come from I need to
know his backstory as an artist it'll
inform his design I got some real good
ones here for you okay
pastel world says Pizza man was an
Olympic ice skater who turned into a
crime-fighting
mullet rocking vigilante who destroy his
enemies with pepperoni with the
pepperoni frisbee of destruction oh he's
got a pepperoni frisbee he's real
these are all these none nod canonical
you can choose okay I can pick and
choose his origin I feel that I like the
idea that he just sort of peels off
pepperonis from his body and throws them
at his enemies like that's a fun idea to
me Myka Pittman says that the backstory
of the pizza man is with a world filled
with pineapple villains Pete's man comes
to save the day oh my god I love that
yes he eradicate Saul pineapple related
things they did they have no place on
pizza man's body his body is a temple
and pineapple does not belong on it with
everyone's thing against pineapple pizza
man it's just weird it's like really
sweet like I just I think a pizza is a
very savory food you know I feel you so
this is where it starts to get messy
when he told me you only have seven
minutes left
actually no pizza man needs beautiful
eyes so this is this kid in a dragon
suit is eating the gummy bear from that
suggestion and he has another gummy bear
about to be eating in this this hand
I destroy that's not a gummy bear at all
and you just finish
all right a beautiful beautiful pizza
man he's a little effeminate but that's
okay you know you don't need to he
doesn't need to be super super manly
I'll get to color let me just finish
sketching out the rest I'm gonna go I'm
gonna just like pump up the speed then
can't believe that much time went by
here we go all right
vigilante Pizza superhero oh I'm feeling
this yeah definitely one of my finer
works okay time to finally color its
color down yeah
does the chat have a favorite pizza
place what's the consensus there I'll
work on it work all right I can't find
who wrote it but I loved the line the
pizza man wasn't created he just is he
just a hiss that's beautiful that is a
beautiful sentiment about this creep
this person Jessica Jones says I've
really been staring at pizza man's legs
for 17 minutes here I'll help you out
there there you go yeah this is about to
be real messy y'all yes uh gotta get
some good luck shots in here there we go
all right you let me just leave it like
this I can just sort of render the legs
forever we need to maybe let's zoom out
okay yeah I'll just zoom out for now
what a beautiful man you know what he'll
have hair he doesn't need it but he'll
have it there we go
language that suggests that it's dragon
kids birthday
dragon was birthday and no one showed up
so he's currently eating gummy bears no
that is a very good assumption to what
I'm drawing also don't give me more
things to draw I'm trying to finish that
was a back story okay okay I love it I
love it okay yeah I like I like that our
characters we're making or getting like
mythos like we can adapt one of these
adapt these guys into something yeah all
right time to color let's give him some
good good melty cheese this is I don't
know if this is a drawing suggestion but
bland cheese says I want to see some
grease on pizza man some grapes on pizza
man Reese Reese oh I think that's just a
way I know what to do
he's sort of okay so here's here's pizza
man's deal all right
he's actually he's just he's sort of
done getting greased and now there's
just like a pool of grease underneath
him where he he's been dripping all day
there yeah he's sweaty you know he's
been he's been out in the Sun someone
left him there
I'm really excited for what you're
drawing I think I'm the one who drew
something in the very this is very
strange I gotta say I took this a little
far yeah I don't know
I'm happy you're the one who went far
yeah you're doing a wholesome family
friendly dragon kid definitely doing a
wholesome family fortune I have gone off
the deep end yeah you guys are kind of
drawing each other's stuff yeah we're
good places here yeah
what a strange turn of events this is
this is an ode to you Jason
thank you all right he's gonna be just a
super yeah yeah ah yes
he's beautiful gorgeous alright we only
got a couple more minutes Jason yeah
gotta hustle
he's looking a little alligator ish but
I kind of I like what I did yeah yeah
okay the chat is a big fan Jason oh
thank you
finally the the comments section likes
me know they've always been there for
you
all right and there's his grease puddle
below his feet perfect hot sweaty pizza
grease face of doom 'no saying this is a
Freaky Friday sort of situation oh yeah
TGIF it is indeed Friday he's gonna have
piercing blue eyes he's a handsome pizza
man I want I kind of want to like draw
my son in this a little bit yeah you
should
my son has like lots of like wavy hair
saw like
what is a mate for my pizza man Oh
oh god no I hate I would see that's what
I was trying to avoid with this I was
trying to avoid like the dangly cheese
the dangly cheese I know nothing's
original yeah I'm doing pretty good now
I feel a little bit more confident yeah
I'm feeling good about this yeah this is
something you know I think right now I'm
just making him even more my son by
adding the hair my son has very like big
and wild hair okay and that he just
pulls on all day oh so I'm just adding a
little bit of that
all right pizza man is done this is as
gross as he's ever gonna look I already
feel ashamed to have drawn this yeah I I
mean I like it yeah I could keep going
definitely but I think I can stop here
as well yeah howdy how do you think you
did Jason I what the internet was I I
wanted to draw the 20th it's 24 hours
later
127 hours later but I just got way too
problematic um so I but I like what I
drew okay yeah this is cute how do you
think he did um I'm surprised my mind
went here but I guess since we've
arrived I I'm not too disappointed it's
uh you know he's ready yeah ready for
action you know start the bidding war
get a movie made Pizza Hut heard oh I'm
sorry
any random pizza chain be sure to take
this up all right all right as I kept
trying to touch it up no no no all right
now look and
I'm gonna just I can move my seat left
I feel really tall right now okay oh my
god this is really good Wow and I had to
draw that so wow this is amazing
he's super fun he's definitely
performing at a bachelorette party yeah
that's the thing that's why you can book
him look him now this is great I love
his pose I love he's eating the gummy
bear yeah a lot of good stuff lot of
stuff to love here this is crazy hair
it's amazing he looks like he's really
about this job he's just like yo I'm
about to do a performance I'm here watch
out he's taking up space watch out y'all
my chance this is character development
Jason oh yeah great drawing sorry I took
the weird mantel away that's fine I was
trying to get weird but I was like let
me play it safe nah he's awesome it was
a great guy this is great I love it so
much well I know yeah I just love pizza
man pizza man it's a good suggestion
just I love that his description is
pizza man and his name is pizza man yeah
Pizza Man pizza man Pizza Man pizza man
this is first and last name it's like
Mario Mario yeah Mario Mario that's man
pizza man yeah yeah man I like I like
this because I don't have to stick to a
character design that I'm like trying to
remember which is the normal format of
the show mm-hmm it's just like they said
draw this let me
draw it how I see it yeah here we go
yeah yeah no yeah this kids great oh
yeah what I really enjoy do it again
let's get weird yeah yeah I really
enjoyed this all right Thank You
internet Thank You internet a blast and
a half yeah yeah in this quiet
changeover let's start getting
suggestions for Kevin and Jackie who
will be trying momentarily I had to take
a picture of this for my wife yeah I'm
deleting this from existence just
kidding all right stop recording it
saved
I'll be watching from my desk as these
suggestions start rolling in guys what
type of things do you like drawing okay
I hate the worst if you draw wait was
that a question for us there's a
question for you guys yeah okay I want
to steer him in the right direction at
least okay I like drawing characters
people I'm not great with animals
therefore everybody's gonna suggest
animals you showed them there your
weakness the digital is your first flaw
what about you Jay he is currently
wearing a microphone I'm wearing oh good
thing you told me I was about to start
saying every curse word I knew glad we
stopped it um do I like drawing I like
drawing everything okay
I'll draw I'll draw a pineapple I'll
draw a bird
I'll draw Naruto I'll draw pipes
I'll draw streets
oh yeah let's do that
what whoa what will I never ever in my
whole life draw Kevin and once again as
we're getting these suggestions in guys
let's make sure to avoid copy written
material because we won't do it we won't
do it Jackie
so we're not gonna draw Ronald McDonald
from McDonald's we are not going to draw
Ronald McDonald from McDonald's Cheetos
guy Chester cheeto Chester cheeto yeah
he's a real cool dude with attitude you
guys gonna get rolling on some screen
recording okay let's do that you don't
have to let's do it
I simply refuse I am rolling on my
screen recording oh my god my glove
what are you aware that you can't smudge
the screen it's too cuz I got sweaty
hands yes Kevin sweaty old sweaty you
don't know my last name
how long have we been sitting across
from a little screen recording this is
BFV five nine seven five to go Jackie
thanks that is the illustrious Matt Rio
I didn't know Matt's last name until
this very moment as well you need to
learn last name what do you think it's
Kevin Smith the real first yes
oh no well I guess Kevin Smith is not a
very uncommon name all right well we're
gonna do a traditional cuz we're rolling
on all three cameras we're gonna do a hi
I'm Kevin I'm Jackie yeah yeah you want
to start yeah
hey I'm Jay how about with a little bit
of
with a little bit a little bit of energy
I know it's afraid I know it's a Friday
at 5 p.m. and I warn uncle hey listen we
all want to go home but we're stuck in
this dungeon until right not trapped us
in the art dungeon the ad if you will
let's not start that got him do it
hey I'm Jackie hey I'm Kevin and today
we are joining whatever I don't know I
didn't know you want to do it again no
okay
hey I'm Jackie hey I'm Kevin and today
we're gonna be drawing whatever the
internet tells us we have no choice but
to listen this is a replay of a
previously recorded live stream so if
you see or hear us doing any so if you
see us shouting out anyone it's in the
chat that you can't see
actually we're seeing you right now oh
yeah let me do that let me do that again
so this is you guys have seen it live
all right so this is a replay of a
previously recorded live stream the chat
on the live stream will be telling us
what to draw as embodied by the voice of
our producer Matt Matt hey we're gonna
start throwing suggestions at you okay
if something gravid if you grab a page
or something you're gonna you're gonna
drive okay something crap this is not
what I said
you said gravis all right if if
something grabbed my attention that's
true to draw it do you know if it that
draw oh I should be a town crier
you should I'll start making
announcements on the top viewed videos
in the middle of
canteen I'll just start serving
6,000,000 mousse with a wait we got
Lexie Borja don't know how to pronounce
it
dinosaurs in burlesque outfits we got
call me a cat on a boards gate boarding
on an alligator not sure how that one
works okay we got a teenager learning to
use an element of your choosing this is
just avatar that's the log line of
Avatar The Last Airbender that they
brought in let's see here we got a lot
of a big bad scary villain being
defeated by a baby we got avatar okay is
that true people just want us to draw
out it's all right that's avatar the
last airbender yeah
Aang is a baby kind of he's young please
draw mole rats
we got a reverse centaur a reverse oh
yeah so like horse top human person
bottom yeah you should do that I'm not
gonna do that it's gonna be horrifying
yeah I don't know how to draw horses
that's but well that's what's gonna make
it even better now yeah do you think I
should do that I think so yeah artists
Lee suggests a potato based superhero
okay keep them coming
come on keep them come on Internet but
on the top of the list is the Centaur
thing but I feel like heaven is weary of
his own spy if I if I grab my phone and
get reference for a horse if I grab a
horse I grab a horse from the from the
cage yeah can we do that does the cage
have horses we got a space pirate
princess
that's from everything is connected
space pirate princess that's a lot of
things space pirate princess Monica
Hernandez says zombie can't zombie care
something you should do zombie can't why
should i do zombies Kat why should I do
anything you tell me - fair enough
[Music]
all right keep them coming in the next
keep them coming
Matt you got a read faster oh okay well
so many so many copy written suggestions
them oh you gotta you got a three can't
you copy right yeah I don't know what
brands are I was born yesterday
like a spider pig keeps coming up can't
do that that's that's a thing yeah yeah
Oh a spider the big ignore the simpsons
one that was copyrighted by God who
invented spiders and pigs yep we got a
cat doing an electric guitar a lot of
cat stuff cat mouse doing a tango
we got a weightlifting mermaid adorable
ninja chicken
ninja chicken I like poop monster
monster that would be my vote avocado
lady is that a thing that's what we do
what is that they just want us to go out
we just want they just want the same I
see I see
sharks with human teeth not so much
there a cat in a mousetrap Jackie as a
cat you take that back whoever said that
Jackie as a squirrel you take that back
oh oh you you mentioned one more time
that I'm I'm a furry oh I'm gonna just
get peeved I think if I don't like the
next couple suggestions I'll do zombie
cat you'll do that weak-ass cat was cute
a couple a couple more a couple more
Internet
ooh that's this is a lot of pressure
oh I heard earlier a Cthulhu working no
Cthulhu it's the squid monster I think
at this point he's public domain
yeah he's for sure public Cthulhu
working his summer job
Cthulhu working a summer job you could
do that Cthulhu is it all powerful
demonic
which is why he's I mean he's just I'm
saying he can't be copyrighted he would
kill you that's true no that's true
it'll own me you're mortal hmm I
understand a lot of what these
suggestions we just need to choose
something okay I'm gonna look at what
Cthulhu looks like I haven't like that
yeah I think you could do that really
cute okay okay a lot of lot of heat on
Jackie as a squirrel yeah oh I'm not
drying myself as a squirrel but if I
draw you as a squirrel oh I will and I
can bring a knife on set and destroy one
of the two Cintiq that were donated to
us so kindly by Wacom all right no
Jackie as a squirrel it was kind of
scary I'm gonna draw this I'm gonna talk
Cthulhu had a summer job working a
summer job okay before I pick what
summer job can I tell you a funny story
please do I thought his name was shoot
Lou oh really
for like until college really and the
only reason I was corrected is cuz like
I said it out loud in front of like 16
people they're like what you see it
happens sometimes but like my brain just
looked at like see th and ooh and then I
didn't read any of the letters in
between it so yeah it's not she it's
hard to pronounce yeah I mean like if
you were to never bring this up in a
conversation you would never learn how
to say exactly so actually not my fault
it was HP Lovecraft's fault it's his
fault that he did not phone you and tell
you how to pronounce it yes agree yeah
all right let's get Kevin a drawing here
all right you guys give me something
give me something a clown as a mobster a
monk fighting a grizzly bear Jesus
wearing a Gucci shirt he's just wearing
a Gucci shirt let's
yeah they're really Oh Kevin as a
squirrel Kevin as a squirrel now that's
a suggestion I can get behind Kevin as
this girl alright I'll do me as a
squirrel what you want me to do me as a
squirrel good at drawing you I am very
good at drawing myself Jess that's true
yeah but you don't want to draw a horse
a reverse centauri love the reverse
center we love people like the reverse
'ti would you like me to draw the
reverse thing but I think people would
really enjoy seeing the horrific entity
that is your reverse centaur all right
Internet do you want to see me draw a
reverse centaur the answer is yes of
course I mean you have to pose it as a
versus question like should I draw
should Kevin draw a reverse centaur or
himself as a squirrel go ready go and
while we wait for the lag I'm gonna grab
my phone no wait I have it right here
you silly Billy
what what summer job should go through
have I give up to me again what summer
job should Cthulhu have I was thinking
lifeguard
I was thinking flipping burgers flipping
burgers ya know he doesn't know how to
cook but that's why it's funny no no no
he would never get that job that's the
Internet no no no what what job should
Cthulhu have I was thinking a just a
simple cashier you know with a cute
little apron how are you today sir yes
that could be good that could be good
yeah yeah okay there's an anime about
monsters that work in a bookstore what's
it called I don't remember but it's cute
there's like a skeleton
I believe it yeah do you believe I could
make something up right now and you'd be
like yeah I believe it sounds really
yeah yeah sure sure yeah Oh a little
shade in the chat Barbara V says Kevin
will do him anyways wait you're gonna
dry yourself anyway Oh Barbara be be my
mom mom is that really gets my mom what
the hell is that really your mom my
mother is in the chair
right now trolling me if she real is
that are you like lying or is not lying
I guess it would be weird a weird joke
to be like that ones my mom I guarantee
you Barbara V is my mom I love Kevin's
mom Kevin's mom is the best can we get
some hearts in the chat for Kevin's mom
but I don't see this chat filled up with
hearts I'm gonna go sicko mode where you
got we we will love the squirrel squad
just squirrel emojis all day people want
the squirrel Jackie I'm doing myself as
a squirrel I guess so did were there any
job suggestions if not I'm doing there
cash register start just start drawing
start I've seen the chicken nuggets all
day so maybe he works at like a fast
foods fine maybe he works at chicken
nugget he does all right let's get drawn
alright 20 minutes
Oh 20 minutes we should have started
drawing maybe 30 minutes ago well we
kept vetoing suggestion we did we were
being a little picky yeah but you told
me we could only pick one yep so you got
I got I was like oh [ __ ]
alright the hartsey requested j-o parts
for my mom alright chef Barbara V also
mom please don't troll me okay I'm live
on the Internet in front of everyone
that means you should do it more Barbara
stop it I love love love your mom
alright I got I got a lot more job see
dozens if you need one you think you get
it uh yeah give it to me I'm just gonna
get lifeguard we got swim instructor we
got ice cream parlor
we got a parlor cuz they need to be like
scooping yeah yeah I was I like the
chicken nugget one but I think I like
ice cream a little more yeah let's do
doesn't don't ice cream parlor people
come with little hats yep and then you
could put them in like a little apron Oh
a little apron mm-hmm
I get the best of both worlds oh if you
look up ice cream parlor outfit you just
get a lot of uncomfortably sexy
Halloween costumes
that's not what I work internet good
work guys that's exactly what I wanted
hmm where's like a little in and out
that's the modern comparison should I
make him angry no I'm gonna make him
cute he's really yeah you have to do I'm
cute he's really happy at this new job
yeah he's finding a new place for
himself yeah I hope it really finds love
in this lifetime
Jackie what do you know about the live
octopus baby
he's an octopus baby octopus baby hey
I'm walking here
hot dog get your hot dogs remembered
something funny okay alright alright
alright alright a squirrel that looks
like me where's Barbara I miss her is my
mom still in the chat or his people are
people scared her off she's scared of
all the spider pigs in the chair oh yeah
he's got its little tentacles mm-hm
I'm giving the squirrel very small ears
because of you notice it's about me
Jackie but I have very small ears I
can't really tell comparatively like I
can't I got to compare it to another ear
to be sure some other years in here good
some other ears good some other ears in
the chat um if you have an ear say uh uh
in all caps thank you big forehead do
you guys know that Kevin has a gigantic
form a gigantic forehead I just it's
just it grows every time I see Kevin it
gets a little little bigger you're gonna
be you're gonna block out the Sun one
day one of these days one of these days
Matt are there any questions in the chat
for us oh yeah ask us questions or don't
in the end I cannot tell you what to do
let's get some questions in the chat
does ask me a question I probably won't
answer it but maybe I will and that
would be cool I'll say your username
that seems like what you want Chet is
just getting through the odds Oh
to celebrate have any ears guys yeah
like you guys are like what is it about
a second thank you stop and sleep what
animal just like copies each other until
it dies I think it's Annie
what lemon lemons lemon that's a fruit
that's a fruit Kevin
may we've we have had to talked about
this at some point but uh I don't know
the answer for either you black sheep
Inc suggest what is you guys favorite
cartoons oh did I feel like I don't
think anyone's ever asked us though okay
Jackie what is your favorite cartoon huh
I actually you go first I have to think
about it I just got a spam call
robocalls
my my current favorite cartoon is Bob's
my current favorite cartoon is Bob's
Burgers Bob's Burgers is amazing yes
that's a really good movie and people
have said that my character designs
remind them of about burgers and I take
that as a compliment because it is
absolutely true opposite burgers but I
would say my favorite cartoon of all
time would probably be freakazoid oh my
god really
you remember freakazoid well I mean I
know from the 90s
I know freakazoid but you know him I do
know personally yes I went to high
school with that came out yeah is he
cool he's actually has the the the
show's popularity got to him that's so
sad to hear yeah that's a bummer it's a
bummer you know domi your heroes I guess
not uh what's your favorite cartoon I
want to think about it was my favorite
cartoon of all time I don't know if
there's one that's my favorite but I
think when I was a kid the most I've
ever watched of a cartoon was probably
Powerpuff Girls really yeah I was gonna
I was gonna guess it was some type of
anime like Sailor Moon or I guess if oh
if we're talking
enemy as well cuz I was only thinking of
western cartoon oh yeah okay but if
we're including anime yeah Sailor Moon
Sailor Moon over Naruto yeah cuz Naruto
came kind of later in my life
okay Sailor Naruto came when I started
learning about mortality and I was like
it's really cool that people
we started learning about mortality when
people started dying in art Oh what and
they would say cool things before they
died and I'd be like what it's cool to
die I don't know how serious it is yet
no yeah lots of Sailor Moon in my life
recent cartoons
I do love Bob's Burgers Bowser is so
good it's a good one oh I just started
to go and birdie Koko and birdies
records really good unfortunately got
canceled
I know I like Bojack horseman that's a
good one yeah it's good
did you ever watch The Venture Brothers
kind of I watched it when I shouldn't
have I think what do you mean what you
shouldn't know you when I was when I was
it up a little late and I wanted to
watch cartoons or and my parents didn't
know what Adult Swim meant I was like
this is drawn it's for children huh it
sure wasn't I'm recently catching up on
it and I love it you love it really good
yeah love it love it
well that's what's dandy it's right in
my wheelhouse any other questions from
the internet yeah I got a good one we
talk about it superheroes a lot on this
show
mm-hmm tiny Time Lord asks if you were a
superhero what would your superpower be
Wow okay what would be your superpower
yours would be being a squirrel
apparently I don't know what do you
think I would have Kevin Oh are we gonna
do it for each other let's do it for
each other I think it would get more
interesting results otherwise I'm gonna
say something stupid like I wish I had
teleport so I don't have to walk anymore
well that's actually kind of what I was
gonna say for you next question for you
what superpower would I want you to have
how do you feel about SuperSpeed that's
pretty cool cuz I feel like you would be
a lot happier if you didn't have to wait
around as much hmm I think I would love
to just flex on people for being really
fast that too you'd be like hey
slowpokes hey slowpoke
oh you're paying for an uber huh watch
this and then I get there and then you
get there yeah so that's what I would
choose for you what would you choose for
me
mmm mayhaps the power to change
someone's mind like Inception no just
like a yes or no decision yeah do you
want to go get ice cream
yes wait wait let's try it out do you
want to go get ice cream yes now we'll
never get ice cream okay or no I don't
know here's how it should be first say
no no do you want to go get ice cream I
think your superpower would be that you
flies you just totally denied me a bit
there Jackie that could have been a
great bit I don't even like ice cream
you know like ice cream oh yeah I hate
all things that are fun apparently I
don't like ice cream because it hurts my
teeth I have like brittle teeth do you
yeah like anything too cold hurts my
mouth
that's what fortunate I know isn't that
stupid why did the human body evolve in
this way how's it going coming it's
going pretty good I'm lining I'm having
a good time whining is wrong I got a
great question from Ruby artwork love
you Ruby artwork Ruby artwork we are
baby artwork the question is how do you
color faster are there any tips and
tricks that you have to color and eye
drawing faster I'll take this one
drawing or coloring color
so Ruby artwork you want to know how to
color faster and I will tell you one
thing that I've started to do
on draw-off learning from jackie is to
simply duplicate my line art layer and
use the paint bucket tool in order to
fill it in now in my world of print
media that is not a good way to do it
because you want to do what's called
trapping and I'm not going to bore you
with what trapping is but for screen art
it's perfectly acceptable and it's a
much quicker way to to color I can tell
you how I color how do you call it
Jackie it's quite fast for me what so
here's a here's something that I'm gonna
do right now on the screen instead of
paint bucketing right away what I do is
I'll usually magic wand it first okay
which magic wand will just select what
like all the closed spaces on the inside
so if I click here like select the
inside of Cthulhu's face but as you can
see you know it's like you are your
lines have to be closed or also start
seeping into the other things and you
don't want that so you can either close
your lines or you can experiment with
the tolerance of your magic wand the
lower it is the less wiggle room they'll
give you to go through the line so like
right now if it's 3200 try oh nevermind
that example if I try to do it like this
it'll go out of this like open line and
select everything but maybe if it was
one it'll be okay
nope but sometimes it works for you so
yeah try it out try using magic wand and
then I'll make a layer beneath and I'll
color and OBO buh-buh-buh-buh I hope
that answer your question
is the artwork Ruby was it Ruby artwork
Ruby oh good ol Ruby are good all Ruby
artwork okay I have a great question
that I want to know the answer to oh
it's Matt's question
my question Asami yuzawa love asks if
you could have contributed to any
cartoon or anime I'm assuming in history
what would it be it was pretty good wow
that is a great question
spirited away yeah I wish I made that
single-handed just by yourself by myself
I wish I worked on it but I Det I
definitely was born the year it came out
ah geez I don't know if I have an answer
to that question I'm gonna think about
it
well we actually have 10 minutes so we
got to go to the next question sorry I'm
gonna go with freakazoid again
freakazoid yeah I love that guy it
really informed my sense of humor oh
yeah love that cool answer when I get it
the answers or she likes aggro so I like
joke it's all right I left start
trolling you by calling you bro um you
can't troll me when Barbara is in the
chat
what color is Cthulhu green is he green
a dark green at least the times that
I've seen what does a chat think what
color should Cthulhu be tell you in a
minute
yeah tell I will learn the answer to
that in 10 seconds from now oh and
here's another question that I will
learn in another 30 seconds from now
what flavor of ice cream should this be
[Music]
and should it have toppings if so what
time wrinkles rainbow sprinkles I mean
he's like a horrifying demon whatever he
wants like blood on it no no sprinkles I
mean blood just hits the spot in a
different kind of way I have a question
this is me Matt what Matt has a question
in the chat and you it may be answered
it or you don't have to answer it maybe
can't remember what has been your
favorite drawing that has come out of
draw off you've done or maybe other
people have done oh yeah what about ones
that other people have done I haven't
really seen all of them you don't really
watch this show not not all the time
yeah I do watch some of them and then
I'm like I was there for this I really
love i really loved Kira Shrek back when
we did that that was so long ago you
know what else I don't say I really like
I already forgot to do it I really I've
said it before but I really liked your
Patrick Starr hmm which one I'm the
original spongebob the original sponge
because it was very cute mm-hmm
and now whenever I think of spun Farwell
now whenever I think of Patrick I think
of that drawing whenever I think of
sponge up I think of Patrick all right I
got colors for you colors for Cthulhu
yes all right
hot pink seems to be on the top of the
list all right you guys you guys are
quite you guys are quite devilish yeah I
don't know if that's correct but I mean
if the internet says it it must be true
right yeah I've never ever distrusted a
fact from the internet yeah everything
on the internet is correct you don't
even have to do your research at that
point you know and and mint chocolate
chip is the most popular flavor
guys are weird it's weird that's a weird
choice but sure you know you guys don't
want blood toppings
I think this is too cute I think I
preferred it when I drew that cat with a
human feet remember those good old days
oh those good old days when I drew cat
with feet all right so should I should I
make kazoo the hot pink is that what's
happening here huh that's what the
internet wants all right do it Jackie
okay are there any more questions ask us
a question have you guys ever tried
painting yes you have yeah
you've tried painting but I said how did
it go I did I painted still-life well I
did figure drawing painting when was
this
this wasn't school I was very difficult
it's very hard not only do you have to
paint like draw them alike but you also
have to paint which is very hard you
know painting gets expensive it really
is yeah yeah I did some painting in high
school mm-hmm I never got good at it
mm-hmm but I held on to my paints for
years and years for years and years and
then I finally gave them to a young
artist friend of mine yeah
and that man's name was Albert Einstein
famous painter famous painter so on top
of that gillian h asks for a beginner
what would be easier painting or drawing
you guys might say drawing but you think
that's the case for every I'm gonna go
with drawing yeah I feel like drawing is
like a fundamental skill yes you can
build your paintings yeah basically
whatever you do you just gotta know how
to draw yeah like you just gotta yeah
one day I'm gonna learn how to draw if
you want to know how to draw cartoons
you still gotta know how to draw real
people yes just the way it is true it'll
make you better at drawing cartoons if
you know how to draw real people
for a little extra time cuz I haven't
even started coloring whoa
so it's all for your convenience yes
Jackie do you like drawing live on the
Internet
it has no positive or negative effects
you are completely neutral I am I have
there's just no emotion attached to such
a thing there's no emotion is attached
to a lot of things you do yeah I think
so
are you dead sad Jack a little bit huh
if you look into my eyes if you look
closely if you if you look take off my
shoes
oMG if you look closely into my eyes you
can see that there is no more happiness
or joy only suffering okay Jackie you're
making the Internet feel really
uncomfortable Jackie
their life is gonna end 10 seconds what
was that was that the ring yeah did we
just do the ring yeah I could
technically really do that let's just do
it one more time okay Oh can you walk
can you walk like Samara good I mean I
don't I've never actually watched it I
was too young when it came out also I
don't like our movies I just brushed my
hair too we were doing drawing as
episode has gone off the rails
how did she walk can you get up and I'm
not gonna get up and do it okay we like
just kind of yeah yeah but she sounds
like she's doing a fortnight she's not
she's like herky-jerky
you like would you describe the ring as
a herky-jerky definitely no it's a
herky-jerky movement also stop you're
scaring me this is a suggestion from the
chat and certainly not from me Matt not
from that from the chair from the jet
finish your drawing okay
seems like we got a bunch of naysayers
there like they seem to be having a
little too much fun not drawing just
wanna clarify that was from them and not
and not mad from me only Oh
so Matt just used the chat as a form of
validation where he was like I really
wish they would stop whatever they were
doing and draw and he saw one person
said it was like now's my chance I'm
gonna make his head shiny do you guys
have any tips for line art tips for line
art Jackie who doesn't stroke undo until
it's done I lost to ask
say that again Jackie Oh tips for just
for line art your liner you draw one
fast line hope it's good
and then
you undo until it's perfect you undo for
so long yep
also smoothing in Photoshop you can turn
on smoothing for your brushes you gotta
practice having confident lines that's a
thing confident like you need confidence
in your lines guys all right we're
getting there Matt Kevin can you explain
this method of coloring you're doing
okay so this method of coloring I'm
doing is not how I suggested that you do
it before the reason I'm doing my
coloring this way is because there's a
lot of open forms on this character and
if I were to just duplicate the line art
and start using the paint bucket tool it
would fill up the entire screen so what
I'm doing right now is I'm just
outlining in the color in the flat color
and then I'm going to take the paint
bucket and to fill it like that takes a
little bit longer but at least you know
you have a closed-form to work with this
guy right this guy with his tips and
tricks' almost like I know what I'm
doing J what no I've never heard such a
ridiculous claim did I do to you I'm
kind of just guessing
why does my Cthulhu look like a
barbershop guy what was he like red and
white kind of mm-hmm I'm committing to
it don't know if it's smart but that's
what life is about it's about making
mistakes man I'm learning from them yeah
man
we'll play whale I love this question
from Andrew Blissett
Andrew placet hit us with it who is your
first cartoon crush oh my god Jackie who
was your first card Yugi from Yugi oh
yes oh not Yugi but when you geek
becomes cool because he's using the
pyramid whatever yeah I don't really
remember the details yeah but I was like
wow what a guy that Yugi's hmm I also
sorry everybody I really like Gary from
Pokemon Gary Gary is like oh really yeah
oh you like the bad boy yeah I like the
bad ones oh he's not bad he's a he's a
good guy you know yeah but he's cool
like a bad guy yeah I like the Ninja
Turtles but I couldn't quite understand
why I didn't like them that much and
later I found out it's because I I
wasn't her furry sure I was like I think
I liked but they're not human but if you
like them that's fine there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing wrong
with being a furry if you never if you
make fun of people for being furries
you're no fun
all right I'm gonna give her a really
lame answer in a very like whiteboy
answer Jessica Rabbit yep oh my god I
hate this I'm sorry I'm sorry what she
was ubiquitous when I was a kid I know
but I just I wish you were just a little
less less of a white are you disappoint
me okay you know what I'll let it go
this time but only this time all right
if you ever pull this again what what
are you gonna do oh you don't even know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna I'm gonna
whoop all sorts of but I'm gonna whoop
your butt I don't whip Jessica but I'm a
whoop your dog's butt I'm a dog well get
one cuz then your Pittsburgh and then
I'll whoop its bud I'll get you a dog
it'll be very lovely they'll have a
wonderful time with it it's blood
all right how you doing done all right
I'm just gonna do a little shading and
then I'll be done just a little bit just
a little bit just a little bit not a not
a ton
my hair is probably all messed up from
doing that yeah cuz was it worth it
though a little bit I'm gonna look up
what she walks like I didn't know she
even fun fact about her walk I do know
this they filmed it they filmed it where
she was actually calling away from the
camera and then they reversed it that's
really scary it's really scary the first
time I saw Samara come out of the TV in
the ring I slept with the lights on for
like three nights and I was in my 20s I
mean it's so pretty it's like one of
those scariest movies right yeah it's
horrible it's horrifying horrifying I
kind of regret making him red and white
doesn't really work with them with a
pink that here yeah I'll just fix it
somehow well the internet wanted him
pink so really just blame it on them
yeah what is wrong with you guys you
guys are the worst
you I just can't get over how awful
every single person in the chest
stop it's just you we love our views
especially you right over there yeah I
can't I can't stand that guy yep that's
definitely me definitely me as a
squirrel
[Music]
that's chuckling so it's exactly that
means that means Barbara is back baby
Barbara is not the only one who's
noticed how how well you've done Kevin
mom you're still in the chat
I accidentally removed my tools from my
screen what how do I get it back reset
the workspace
oh it's back don't worry about it I
never even had to worry about it all
right homestretch homestretch come on
come on Kevin come on you can do it quit
screwing around you can do it Kevin
all you have to do is believe in
yourself believe in your thumb and you
can know anything else first buh buh buh
buh buh buh buh I'm done that's fine you
don't have to look at me like that
any final questions from the chat yeah
we're gonna leave soon and never come
back
I'm looking that's the question it's a
pretty good statement from me
oh I did like this one Abraham Gonzales
if you were a cartoon character who
would you be who would I be that's
Kevin's question doo-doo-doo I would be
and that's okay no I would be gene from
Bob's Burgers cuz he seems like are we
picking characters that you think we are
know that we would want to be here's why
I want to be gene from Bob's Burgers
because he has the most confidence of
any kid that I've ever seen that's true
like he is just gene and he is awkward
and weird but he owns it and he loves it
and he lets his freak flag fly all the
time he's amazing and he's an
inspiration I do I love that episode
where he like is in love with that
toilet yeah and the guys like does this
to him and he goes now he wants to
switch eyes with I was like that's a
really funny joke yep what character
would you want to be I want to be this
Cthulhu I drew really an ice cream I
guess that's not really a cartoon
character right I think are you done yes
okay who do I want to be who has a
perfect life in a cartoon yeah that was
the thing cuz I was originally gonna say
one of the Ninja Turtles but those guys
have to fight yeah I don't want to be
like a character that's like cool but
like their life is tragic I want to have
a cushy life no cartoon like why would I
choose to have a bad life smart hmm who
has a wonderful life
who's who's a rich cartoon character
that's not like awful
that's not awful yeah Matt what do you
think well that's a hard they normally
make rich people
yeah they I mean cuz real rich people
are usually not nice yeah I want to be
whatever like what I want to be Clifford
the Big Red Dog
Clifford the Big Red Dog has a wonderful
life really wholesome life he's a big
dog who's not gonna love a big dog
exactly they're gonna be like oh my god
that dog is so huge and also for some
reason it's entirely red but he makes a
lot of mistakes yeah but he's a yeah but
it's always someone else's fault yeah
and like in like his days are like I'm
gonna go to the beach with my other dog
friends who are regular sized oh all my
owners gonna give me some treats
yum-yum-yum-yum all right I am done you
are done OOP I am done I am also done I
have finished Cthulhu at a summer job I
should save this yes you should hice
cream didn't spell it right it's fine
all right how do you think you did I
think I did wonderfully do you think you
did the internet proud do you guys like
my drawing a lot of nose my career is
over YouTube said I can't draw that was
just a joke OC bat hesitating good boy
Matt doesn't like my drawing I think
it's great he says with no I do these
are both great see you like your drawing
I like my drawing how do you think you
did Kevin well it definitely looks like
me as a squirrel um yeah well not hard
to do it was a strange request weird how
much you were into it well but you know
what Jackie they say draw what you know
and I know me and you know you and I
know
you know a squirrel I don't know I
actually have not seen many squirrels
and girl I had to pull up a reference
for squirrels because I don't know what
squirrels look like off the top of my
head it's really really funny why you
really haven't seen that many squirrels
draw squirrel from memory right now no
I'm doing it you think I can't do that
in like two seconds
you got 30 seconds hey corn okay what
we'll see yeah we'll see I'll put him
he's the one getting the ice cream oh
well there you go he has money actually
here yeah okay it's gonna I'm racing the
Acorn to have money on it he's gonna pay
for the ice cream so Wow yeah Jackie
you're a very impressive artist Wow
don't mean to brag but I did make a deal
with the devil for these skills so with
Cotulla with cut to Malou okay with
mister Chuo himself you wanna switch I
guess all right let's do careful nope
all right not looking not looking
did you look a little bit you looked it
was a little I'm scared to see it again
I feel like I'm turning into stone I
looked into Medusa's eyes I'm gonna tell
a funny joke okay I feel like I've
already said this joke but let's say it
one more time why do seagulls live by
the sea why cuz if they live by the bay
they'd be bagels
who's that funny that's good all right
you ready looking in three two one
what is that ah uncomfortable why it
looks like you yeah it looks it looks
like a squirrel but the top of its head
is human but not human oh you gotta get
the forehead and you gotta get the
receding hairline it's good it's just
scary
I like making you uncomfortable with my
drawings it looks like what is it
Chippendales like like annoying cousin
or something Chippendales annoying
cousin that just comes in an episode and
Chip and Dale are like are you doing
here
get out Kevin you have human hair it's
freaking us out I like that I think
that's a good addition thank you I would
watch that you would watch that yeah are
we gonna reboot Chip and Dale Chip and
Dale and Kevin chip Dale Kevin the cdk
yours is adorable Thanks it's you know
what when the internet suggested it I
had a mental image in my head and this
is pretty much what I saw Wow
what actually happened was I used my
superpowers
and dug deep into your brain and pulled
that image out like a claw machine and
just put it on the computer you just
blew my mind but it's it's very cute
it's got a lot of appeal I did think you
were gonna do something a little more to
be a little more super-deformed but I
like this yeah I wanted to give him the
whole body yeah yeah I drew the squirrel
do you like the squirrel yeah your
squirrel is better than mine you did in
like 30 seconds congratulations is that
what you want to hear yeah I just wanted
to hear that I'm better than you in
every way and that I am a perfect and
flawless human being and I can draw
literally anything and everything
without looking up reference great
looking up reference is really good for
you you guys should start doing it
there's nothing wrong with looking at
reverence all right what do you think
about letting the internet decide what
we draw people really like spider pig
people really want to
yeah yeah we couldn't do spider pick no
we couldn't the internet it's also
really bad at listening so what was this
fun would you've done this oh yeah that
was really fun let's do that again yeah
I did I'd liked a lot of the suggestions
but the fact that I could only pick one
made it made me picky mmm I liked it
Samba cat I like I like the cat on an
alligator or whatever yeah surfboarding
that one was cool yeah I would draw so
many cats if I had like two hours yeah I
draw seven cats all right I went from a
million to so we'll have to do it again
right oh yeah sure
should we do this again let's do it
again right now if you guys want more
live streams let's get some eyes in the
chat everyone just starts screaming
let's get some screams in the channel we
get some screams can we get some
blood-curdling screams like murderous
screams in the chat like you are dying
of murder in the chat in the chat please
why are you I was gonna make it weird at
the end no I'm gonna do it through that
camera Oh which one I'm doing to
titillate side camera I'm doing are we
the other one how all why are you always
gonna make it weird at the end you did
that for the episode we did that for the
episode now for the livestream have you
guys seen that vine where they pour the
water on that girl and she goes hello
I'm gonna talk about my hole alright
that's it Thank You internet for joining
us for draw for you we will see you next
time watching goodbye forever
[Music]
it was fun I hope we see each other
again but we should stop because I want
to go home
let's stop you're the one who's still
singing cuz we all want to go Jackie
alright stop streaming Matt click the
stop but now goodbye Internet